foreign
business requirements integrating them
with technology and serving as a link
between multiple stakeholders are all
part of business analyst
responsibilities business analyst job
profiles are pretty profitable and have
a lot of potential and reward well so in
this video we are covering introduction
to business analyst and fundamental
questions after that technical questions
on business analyst before moving
forward please make sure you subscribed
to Simply learns YouTube channel and
press the Bell icon to never miss any
updates coming to fundamental questions
first question is who are the
stakeholders and types of stakeholders
a stakeholder is a person or a group who
have vested interest in the ongoing
project he or she will be affected by
the pace and result of the projects
coming to stakeholders there are three
types of stakeholders one is primary
stakeholders second one is secondary
stakeholders and key stakeholders
next is what is the role of the business
analyst this is the fundamental question
that every interviewer can ask business
analysts have a key role in the
organization performing Financial
operations they are indirectly
responsible for creating economic growth
in the organization the action and
decision taken by the business analyst
will impact on the growth of the
organization this is the most frequently
Asked question can you list out the
skills you have as a business analyst so
the answer is as a business analyst we
must be able to understand the business
objective good communication skill
database knowledge SQL for the analysis
of data
and maintaining it non-technical skill
includes documentation management skill
and requirement analysis business
analyst is responsible for creating
reports and dashboards so we need jira
Microsoft SQL and power bi in this
technique
next is what is what analysis and give a
business application example for this
SWOT analysis is necessary in every
field it is important term for the
success of any business first of all
SWOT analysis stands for strengths
weakness opportunity and threats it is
the duty of a business analyst to create
a strategy for the organization based on
the result of SWOT analysis as a
business analyst we need to take care of
SWOT analysis in each and every project
coming to business application of sport
analysis we can take up Amazon as an
example coming to strength powerful
brand recognition variety of products
and its REITs Amazon has 26 percent
market share in e-commerce weakness
issues with mid-level business product
failures tax avoidance controversy in
countries like us UK and Japan related
to taxation
Etc
opportunity Amazon has the opportunity
to expand its operation capability for
more acquisition
coming to threats Amazon has faced a lot
of controversies in recent years it is
facing a lot of government trials in
crucial countries like Iran Cuba and
North Korea circumstances of cyber
crimes are increasing day by day as it
affects network security of the company
NeXT is one of the hypothetical question
that can be asked in any interview
how will you tackle difficult
stakeholder
dealing with difficult stakeholder is a
skill difficult stakeholder is a person
who holds difficulty in understanding
the project or Pace of it so first of
all listen to the stakeholder carefully
and then deal with the problem coming to
technical questions list out different
stages in sdlc sdlc is an acronym that
stands for software development life
cycles sometimes it is also called
system development life cycle or
application development life cycle it is
used to describe the process of planning
creating testing and deployment of an
information system so what is the role
of business analyst in sdlc business
analysts play an important role in
requirement analysis he gathers data
from customers and then send it to the
product development team so it has 5
important faces first one is planning
then comes requirement analysis here the
role of business analyst is very
important and third is design
implementation and last is maintenance
of the product next is what is uml
modeling uml or unified modeling
language is a general purpose
developmental modeling language that
provides a standard way to Envision the
system it is used to rationalize the
system behavior for the detection and
elimination of the error what is process
design process design is the creation of
a process to achieve specific objectives
it involves the specifying of operating
conditions raw materials equipment and
other aspects of the process process
design also includes the determination
of desired output levels process flow
diagrams and other process
characteristics what are the essential
qualities of an agile business analyst
Ajay is a very famous methodology
nowadays every company uses agile
methodology for the implementation of
this project
an agile business analyst is someone who
understands the agile methodology and is
able to help a team work within that
framework
they need to be able to communicate
effectively be organized and have a
strong attention to detail they should
also be able to work well under pressure
and be able to adapt changes quickly
next comes what is feasibility study a
feasibility study is a thorough analysis
of a proposed project that considers all
elements essential to success in order
to determine the project chances of
success next question is what is invest
i n v e s t explain it this is the
favorite question for every interviewer
in a business analyst interview
independent negotiable valuable
estimable sized appropriately and
testable are all letters that stand for
invest business analyst and project
managers use this phrase to refer to the
provision of high quality services and
goods provided to the clients what is
the contribution of a business analyst
in an organization
business analysts are responsible for
closing the gap between it and the
Business by evaluating processes
identifying requirements and delivering
data-driven suggestions and reports to
Executives and stakeholders requirement
management is the crucial role of a
business analyst the business analyst
job is to sustain needs through ongoing
change in the complicated modern
corporate environment by applying
innovation
why do you prefer canoanalysis and how
is it helpful it is a quality management
tool that aids companies in determining
the wants and need of their clients as
we have already mentioned business
analysts plays an important role in
requirement analysis he is responsible
for Gathering all the data required to
create a product so he is the base of
every company in it can be applied to
enhanced marketing tactics consumer
satisfaction and product development Dr
noriyaki kanu a Japanese expert in
quality management created the keno
model in the 1980s
what are the tools used by business
analyst
jeera and Confluence you might have
heard about jeera and Conference the
collaboration tools jira and Conference
are very effective to collaborate
effectively on projects and share
requirements every business analyst has
to be at least familiar with jira by
using platforms like jira and Confluence
all business stakeholders May engage
with various teams and view the status
of their project Trello Trello is a
project management platform that
business use for teamwork and task
organization Trello is a project
management platform that business use to
by dividing the work into columns on a
board it enables you to manage your
projects and efforts by dividing
complicated projects into smaller more
manageable and reliable chunks of Labor
this helps to simplify and standardize
your work next is Microsoft Visual
project management as business modeling
are two areas where Microsoft Visual
excels it may be used to make data
models project timelines process
flowcharts use case diagrams and many
more
next comes Google Docs Google Docs
provides you with templates for business
research business analyst may share and
collaborate on documents effectively
using Google Docs with the use of Google
docs many business analysts can
communicate with stakeholders about any
kind of file or document
next is what is SRS explain it
SRS stands for software requirement
specification it is a collection of
documents describing the feature of the
application it holds the requirements of
the stakeholders in the project the
critical aspects of SRS are scope of
work non-functional and functional
requirements data model dependencies
assumptions and constraints and
acceptance criteria next is what is BRD
the business requirement document is
referred to as BRD it is an official
agreement between the company and the
client for the creation of the
particular product BRD is a functional
software specification but SRS is
something that both business analysts
write after having direct client
contract it contrasts to SRS which is
designed based on technical skills and
requirements bid is developed by a
business analyst following their direct
connection with the client
what is business modeling business
modeling is a step-by-step approach for
identifying the value proposition for
operating the business the key
attributes of business modeling to
develop strategic plan of an
organization usually the Strategic plan
of an organization will be vision
mission objectives strategies and action
plan next is what is gap analysis and
what are the types of Gap analysis
Gap analysis is the study of the
functional gaps between a system that is
now in use and the system that is being
targeted the difference denotes
adjustment needed to achieve the desired
outcome the difference between a
company's actual and projected earnings
is known as profit Gap the difference
between a company's actual and necessary
worker strength is known as Manpower Gap
the discrepancy between expected and
actual performances is known as
performance cap the difference between
anticipated and actual sales is known as
Market Gap as a business analyst you
need to know about Gap analysis business
analyst will be calculating all these
gaps like Market Gap performance Gap
Manpower gap or it may be profit Gap do
you think a business analyst should be
involved in the testing phase there is
no universally applicable response to
this query because the extent of
business analyst engagement in texting
will vary depending on the particular
project and company however in general
business analysts should participate in
testing since they may offer insightful
analysis of the requirement and
guarantee that the finished product
satisfies the demand of the business
what is bpml business process model and
notation or bpmn is a widely used
graphical notation for modeling business
processes bpmn was developed to give
business users and Technical developers
a standard language to utilize for
describing and communicating business
processes important elements of BPM and
are event and accurate that triggers a
process is called event next is Gateway
a decision point of a process activity
and data object information that is
required or broadly used by an activity
is called as data object
this is the most widely asked question
what is the difference between business
analysis and business analytics as an
aspiring business analyst we should
always know about what is the difference
between business analysis and business
Analytics
business analysis and business analytics
differ in a few important ways while
business analytics experts concentration
on evaluating data to help decision
making business analyst typically focus
on discovering opportunities and
optimizing procedures business analyst
also frequently come from backgrounds
that are more business focused whereas
business analytics specialist frequently
have Superior technological skills
finally while business analytics
Specialists may spend more time working
with data business analyst May
collaborate more closely with business
stakeholders to understand their need
thus we have listed important questions
that are frequently being asked in
business analyst interview questions I
hope this video was helpful thank you
for watching keep learning
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here